about 11,000 charter school students and
parents to send it on New York State's
Capitol building in Albany on Tuesday
they came to protest New York City Mayor
Bill de Blasio's decision to block two
new charter schools from opening next
year and to halt the expansion of a
third you're stopping one of the best
charter schools with the highest grades
and all that that just doesn't make
sense if the school was failing that I
would understand because of the mayor's
decision many parents may have no option
other than to send their kids back to
the regular public schools in their
districts when I found out the news that
the mayor had closed my son's school I
began to cry because the local public
school is not working how what would you
do at the school that works for your
child clothes and you had no other
option we cannot send my son to a
failing school he's been doing so well
and I just I can't send him back like
that I can't say I'm up for failure
mayor de Blasio will allow 16 charter
schools to move forward with their plans
to open next year so what does he have
against these three schools in
particular the answer is that the mayor
is settling old political scores on
behalf of the teachers union the three
schools targeted by the mayor are part
of Success Academy a charter network run
by a former politician named Eva
Moskowitz Success Academy schools post
exceptional test scores and last year
they had about five applicants for every
opening nevertheless at a forum
organized by the teachers union back in
May
de Blasio said it's time for Eva
Moskowitz to stop having the run of the
place she has to stop being tolerated
enabled supported before Moskowitz ran
Success Academy charter schools she was
a member of the New York City Council
and chair of its Education Committee it
was at that time that she made enemies
of de Blasio and the Democratic
political establishment in 2003
Moskowitz held a multi-day hearing on
how union contracts imposed inane work
rules on public schools and made it
nearly impossible for principals to fire
bad teachers we must examine these rules
and discuss them New Yorkers
must know what the rules are and come to
conclusions about which ones are helpful
and productive and which may not be
helpful and productive at the hearing
she went toe to toe with one of the most
powerful political figures in the city's
I want to take this opportunity to
welcome Randi Weingarten the president
of the United Federation of Teachers
that is what the UFT has been trying to
get across this year the issue of
helping us supporting us to help every
single child in our charge is it the
case or is it not the case that a
principal could have to accept a
candidate sight unseen is that correct
or incorrect there is a plan that was
negotiated starting in the mid 60s
between the Department of Education so
my question to you ft just it is it the
case that a principal under any
circumstance could have to take a
candidate without ever having
interviewed them yes or no yes thank you
Weingarten was flanked by Brian
McLaughlin the head of New York City's
Central Labor Council who would later go
to prison for embezzlement
he told daily news reporter Joe Williams
that he showed up because he wanted to
quote remind the City Council members
that the entire labor movement in the
city is watching them they got the
message the elected officials in
attendance including Bill DeBlasio at
the time was a city councilman did
whatever they could to distance
themselves from Moskowitz when a group
of witnesses claimed that the union
contract made it difficult to remove bad
teachers de Blasio was dismissive I
served in the Clinton administration so
I know what spin looks like when I see
it and this is spin and I give you
credit for having put forward a coherent
spin two years later when Moskowitz ran
for Manhattan borough president
Weingarten and the teachers union
campaigned against her she lost the
election and her political career came
to an end
now that he's Mayor Bill DeBlasio is
doing whatever he can to please the
teachers union and undermine Eva
Moskowitz of schools even if it means
taking away the opportunities for
thousands of kids to get a better
education but at Tuesday's rally New
York Governor Andrew Cuomo and other
state legislators threw their support
behind Eva Moskowitz and the kids she
serves to tell you that we stand with
you you are not alone we will set
charter schools in many ways the
governor has more control over charter
schools than the mayor and he may
intervene and provide the facilities
funding that Moskowitz's schools need to
open and expand after all and nobody has
more at stake than the kids who may be
forced to return to their failing
district schools next fall for reason TV
I'm Jim Epstein